the book of boba fett has finally come
to a close as the famous bounty hunter
rallies his forces for battle against
the pike syndicate and its enforcer cad
bain the series goes in some interesting
directions in chapter 5 and chapter 6
which heavily focus on the mandalorian
dinjarin the yoda lookalike grogu and
the legendary luke skywalker but the
finale brings everything back to
tatooine as boba's battle with the pikes
escalates into an all-out war across
moss espa does the finale have
ramifications for the wider star wars
universe more importantly does it tease
what's coming up ahead in the
mandalorian season 3 well sort of
for now
we wait the tension on tatooine cranks
up from the very beginning of the final
season one episode as boba finic shand
and the mandalorians survey the
sanctuary wreckage r.i.p guards with
whip boba also faces an emotional blow
as bane reveals that the pikes are
actually the ones who killed the tuscan
tribe not the nicto sand riders the
massacre is revenge for their attack on
the spice train all of this only hardens
boba's determination to rid tatooine of
the syndicate once and for all but when
the battle for masaspa gets started
writer john favreau and director robert
rodriguez deliver a pulse-pounding fight
for the very soul of tatooine luckily
boba dyn and finnick aren't alone in
their struggle the big cliffhanger at
the end of chapter 6 sees luke skywalker
offer grogu a choice he can either take
the best guard chain mail and return to
din jaren or he can pick yoda's old
lightsaber and train to become a
fully-fledged jedi on one hand it would
be great to see him train in the force
and master his abilities but we all know
that he really belongs with his
surrogate father thankfully favreau
gives fans what they want as r2d2 lands
luke's x-wing in pelimoto's hangar with
grogu sitting comfortably in the pilot
seat because grogu's memory is clouded
he doesn't have many meaningful
connections and although luke and ahsoka
tano are kind to him he's got a much
closer bond with den at least his brief
time with luke means he already has a
better grip on his force abilities than
he did before which is quite useful when
the streets of moss espa erupt into a
deadly fire fight when the other gangs
of the city betray their treaty with
boba attacking boba's enforcers it's not
exactly surprising since the different
factions are clearly just out for money
rather than respect although things
start to look dire when the hordes of
pykes deploy two deadly scorpenic droids
oh dear nevertheless boba has some other
backup to rely on
the devastating power of the scorpenec
droids causes chaos in the battle
because their shields are too strong for
boba's army to blast through with any of
their weapons dinjarin even whips out
the darksaber to try to penetrate the
shields but it has no effect at all
although he probably needs some more
training to carry its way but then the
finale pays off on chapter 3's promise
as boba finally rides his rancor into
battle the monster's power quickly
overwhelms the first scorpenec droid
with a little help from grogo luke's
training comes in handy for the little
green force user as he yanks a key
component from the droid's parts that
makes it vulnerable rogue clearly has a
fondness for shiny metal objects because
it's pretty reminiscent of the way he
grabs that ball from the razor crest in
the mandalorian season one after the
rancor finishes the first droid off boba
steers it to the second quickly
eviscerating it the destruction of the
droids and the sheer power of the rancor
sends the pikes running which is a nice
piece of symbolism tatooine is taking
itself back from its oppressors although
it's not over just yet as cad bane shows
his face again to try to kill boba kad
bane's arrival at the end of chapter 6
calls back to the western genre which
george lucas was originally inspired by
when creating star wars back in the 70s
director robert rodriguez leans into the
gun slinging genre once again for boba
fett's duel with bane in the finale as
they trade insults in a tense standoff
bane even points out they've known each
other a long time calling back to the
times they crossed paths during the
clone wars animated series bane makes it
clear that he might be an old man but
he's still quicker than bobo when it
comes to a quick draw gunfight for a
minute it even looks like bane might
kill boba look out for yourself
anything
is weakness
but this is boba fett so he doesn't go
down that easily instead he uses his
gaffy stick to swiftly knock bane to the
ground symbolizing how his new strength
comes from having a family he even
avenges his fallen tuscan tribe by
killing bane with the stick sure he's a
fan favorite villain but his death has
been a long time coming
cad bane's death causes the few
remaining pikes to retreat let's face it
if he can't take boba fett down who can
so it looks like this is a new era for
tatooine now that the crime lord has
liberated the planet from the pike
syndicate finnic shand even wipes out
that gang's last foothold on the planet
by killing their leader and executing
mayor mock shays leaving either of them
alive would mean that the spice trade on
tatooine could start up again sometime
after the big battle fett reacts
uncomfortably to the moss espa residents
bowing and calling him lord boba he
remarks to fennec that they're not cut
out to rule a surprising comment
considering everything they've gone
through to get here however this is a
new role for fett murderous bounty
hunter turned local hero fennec responds
if not us
then who the finale ends with den flying
his naboo starfighter through space as
grogu sits in the pod behind him the
little green force user even pesters him
to fly at high speeds and then like any
parent reluctantly obliges it's not
clear where they're headed although it's
possible den wants to redeem himself in
the waters of mandalore underneath the
planet's minds
of course it wouldn't be a disney plus
series if there wasn't a post-credits
scene teasing the future of the galaxy
the brief scene takes audiences back to
boba's quarters where cobb banff is
recuperating in the gunslinger's back to
tank where the modifier from chapter 4
is keeping an eye on him this clearly
suggests that van is severely wounded
when shot by cad bane but not killed
it'll be interesting to see how the
modification artist fixes his injuries
although he's definitely going to need
some new armor to wear instead of just a
shirt and a bandana maybe denjarin can
give him some spare besgar in the
mandalorian season 3.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the book of boba fett are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you